[Music]
what up guys
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want yeah and
today's segment is ask
the expert and we have a pro mma fighter
my coach ron here today
what makes you a pro um i get paid to
hit people that's tight
so my question is this i always hear
this urban legend right
where they say like once you become like
a pro fighter like your body
is uh like a registered weapons if you
beat someone's ass
like they can uh charge you with assault
with a deadly weapon is that true
yes you're a registered weapon
um you don't like get registers like
there's not a license i can pump like yo
check it out
weapons but if you uh if you get an
altercation
and you beat somebody up you know if
you're if you have some sort of advanced
belt or your professional fighter um
they show that you have massive
experience in
hand-to-hand combat so if i beat
somebody up even if they pick on me and
i like
knock all their teeth in break their
neck and their arms and stuff like that
i'mma get in trouble because i should
have known better but what if i was a
yellow belt and i just started and i'm
not like a white belt anymore
yeah because at a high level you should
have enough control um where you don't
destroy somebody and put them in massive
i'm a yellow belt though that's just
i'm starting i'm a purple belt at junior
karate
which is taekwondo in fairfax virginia
so
i you could probably beat my ass and be
fine because like i am
you know i got some some practice got
some stuff yeah so
what happens do people like google or
it's like once it gets to the court case
like the lawyer does the research and
like finds out that you're a pro fighter
you've been training
yeah yeah so if i go if i go in the
street and i get a fight with somebody
and i just
i put them in the hospital they're going
to do their due diligence they're going
to find out my background
and then be like hey this guy should
have known better he was overly trained
and
he should have done this to this person
now this person is the victim you know
what happened so
our karate teacher um he got in a bar
fight and he
um beat up a cop and that was at the bar
he screwed no
he he sued the city and then he won
money because
the cop after he got beat up he pulled
out his badge
he started the fight by the way the cop
was a being a tough guy
so he got beat up by our karate teacher
and then he pulled out his badge after
he got beat up and then he booked him
and did all the law stuff and called the
other cops and he's like oh i'm gonna
[ __ ] you guys over
and then because he abused his power
even though he got beat up
um he didn't get like my yeah my my
sensei didn't get in trouble he sued the
city
because the cop abused his power yeah
that's such bad luck for that cop though
he got his ass beat and sue well no i
but imagine like
being in a bar and be like i want to
tell those guys a piece of [ __ ] and you
walk up to him
and then he's a karate instructor like a
little asian dude too right
yeah he's he's like five three five four
yes yeah yes that is sweet justice i
love it when you train though don't you
go like man i can't wait to beat the
[ __ ] out of someone on the street
no it's you know um i started training
when i was 17
and especially at that age right like
let's say when you're like 19 or 20
don't you go i want to beat the [ __ ]
no it's a it's a weird thing so before i
turn 17 i've been in two street fights
outside of fighting
uh yes in my whole life even after i
started training
so before i started training i got in
one street fight and that was with uh my
good friend in high school
he was uh hooking up with my girlfriend
at the time so you fought your own
friend
yeah so i was like meet me at king's
pizza i'm like i'm gonna punch you in
the face
and sure no i walked up punched in the
face blah blah whatever
you don't want to fight him later on
when you know way more [ __ ]
no um well funny enough
a few years later uh we went to a king
in the cage event which is like a mma
promotion
and i saw him and i had that look we
locked eyes i was like are we going to
battle i'll see a king's pizza [ __ ]
yeah you know it's like we're gonna
battle right now and then we just kind
of look he nodded i nodded and then like
we walked our own ways it was like
i'm like okay what happened i was like
we have moved on with life
he became a fighter too i don't know i
just saw him at the event well i'd
assume he has some sort of
he's in he's in the field either as a
fan or as a training or a boy if he was
eating a corn dog i don't think he's one
of the fighters
corn dogs are delicious they are they
fighters don't eat them fighters don't
eat them though you're right yeah yeah
at least not before fight i don't think
yeah that's true it happens and then the
only other time i got in a street fight
was uh
was in around the corner from my my gym
team oyama
it was after a christmas party um i
guess we should share that now it's a
good time
so we're having this christmas party
everybody's having a good time we walk
around the corner
and uh we're driving to go home and this
poor little dude is being mounted by
this big giant dude and just freaking
slapping them i'm like
hey what's going on it's like bae i was
with my girlfriend what was their
relationship why was he just beating
i have no idea they weren't from the gym
so they were just in the parking lot
of the gym um right around the corner
because we're in a roundabout and
they're right over there so as we pull
out
i'm like babe stop the car and i said i
was like hey leave him alone
and then he's like get off get off and
um he started like saying something like
pretty
offensive things um like you cheating
stuff like that
i'm like whoa whoa whoa whoa man i'm
like you guys have the wrong person one
day they're gonna beat you up man
one day it could be right now today's
not that day [ __ ]
yeah so he gets up he like gets rid of
my face i'm like
you're like yes this is what i've been
training for my whole life yeah i'm like
oh man and
regardless of how much training you have
you still get adrenaline with
confrontation you know yeah like even
even like in the street you know someone
pulls you off and road rage comes out
you still get that like dude i'm like oh
man i'm like stuff might happen
but he starts getting my face you better
get out of here freaking jinky [ __ ] i'm
gonna snap the crap out of you i'm
censoring my language a little bit
not because well i don't know if i'm
allowed to do it in here but you can say
whatever you want
but also i don't really curse okay yeah
that's true i also self-censor
randomly um so i'm like whoa whoa i'm
like are you okay buddy's like yeah
yeah he's fine man he's my friend i'm
like he's not that great of a friend if
he's treating you like that
and he's like get out of here now i'm
gonna slap the crap out of you
i'm like i just came to make sure your
friend is okay you're not a nice person
and you go get out of here now he goes
oh
he spits right in my face i'm like
and then like usually i don't get angry
but something with
spit touching my face gets me really
thinking it's a salt that's assault dude
yeah so then i punched him he goes
and then he tackles me and then so i
sprawl and i hit i uppercut him a few
more times
and then he falls to the ground and then
he gets up and then his face is just
dripping blood out of his nose in his
mouth and he's like he gets right back
in my face he's like
you better get the f out of here i'm
going to call the police
i'm like what you attack he attacked you
and he's going to call the police spit
in my face man and then
his friend comes up hey please just
leave us alone and now i start feeling
like
like the bully and i'm like were they
role-playing what the [ __ ]
yeah it was like bad cop do you have a
heart on like
i'm like leave us alone when my friend
beats me up yeah i was like all right no
just just give me my sandals and i'm out
of here man
and then so the guy runs gives and goes
like let's go and then my girlfriend in
the back
and like i've never heard her talk like
this before she's like yeah that's right
[ __ ] you want a mess
and i'm like april she's like why not
like
the heck did you turn ghetto oh like
okay that's like standing next to a tank
and being like yeah you better [ __ ]
run yeah like get your head back in the
car you know
and then so we drive off and she's like
guess what she's like what
and then she plays this thing on an ipad
she got some of it on video
i'm like i'm like you're recording i'm
like well you don't like that that's
sick though
that's like a [ __ ] fight reel yeah
yeah and then yeah it also has an actual
fight wheel too oh that's true
way better but um but yeah so that was
my my fight thing and so if that i mean
honestly if that
i didn't really hurt him that bad but i
i stopped if i would have kept
going and like he would have been in the
hospital he could have easily sued me
and he would have won
for sure because i didn't show her
strength but because i'm training i just
did just enough to him for him to stop
spitting in my face
but did your wife also record all the
friendly talk because you sounded really
polite and friendly yeah
you sound like you're in a commercial a
little bit i don't think you have a very
good friend
i talk very tacky is weird that is how
he talks
i know this is why it's funny because
when people picture
like pro fighters or whatever they think
these like crazy like [ __ ] face
tattoos and [ __ ] yeah but
most of the pro fighters that i know are
some of the most friendliest
chillest dudes you know and the
stereotype just
does not match yeah you have guys like
ron who are very like just
friendly and happy and then you see them
in the ring and they're um
just an animal yeah and then i'm always
wondering right like um
how do you tap into that because you
don't fit the stereotype of
violence and aggression aggression and
when people think fighting they think
violence and aggression right like for
example like
to be it's not
a natural human instinct to want to hurt
somebody
like that's a learned thing you're not
most people i think
you have to teach them how to hit
someone and then uh but like a
like your sport is to hurt
that's the that's the thing that you do
so how do you like
learn that or like tap into that it's a
it's a weird experience you know some
people like
jump off of like uh skyscrapers out of
airplanes people
swim with sharks um fighting i feel like
is one of those experiences where you
get like a feeling that just can't be
matched
um doing anything else and so i'm not
really violent
but i also hit stuff all day long so
it's kind of like
i'm not a violent person i feel like but
i do violent
things all but only in the gym it's it's
controlled how did you even get into it
if you're like
like always chill and like just like a
passive guy how did you get into like
wanting to i'm not a professional
violencer i'm a
i'm i'm an impulse person and so if i
like something i go in and i go all in
like i can't stop thinking about it till
i do it it's full capacity
but you're controlled you're impulsive
but you have self-control
like you know like you're not um
so like like you you you act upon what
you feel
but you also don't let it go outside of
the ring well i mean you just told a
story where you beat the [ __ ] out of it
that was self-defending self-defending i
don't know the gym premise is kind of
but you're not
like my other buddy who who um who's
constantly fighting on the streets
like it's different you know what i mean
like you do have that self-control where
you're not
constantly looking for fighting yeah i
don't i don't look for funny it's just
it's a fun thing to know that i'm able
to put
all this time and all this effort into
somebody into something and then someone
else is doing the same exact thing and
we get to be locked into a small arena
and then we see who can hate each other
the best yeah um there's a very unique
feeling to be able to hit somebody
is hardest and this is something that i
discovered that i just didn't know i
loved until it happened
and just visualized like
boom and you're like i'm like you need
therapy it's weird you know i have no
issues i've had
i've had a great like childhood like
nothing wrong
cause you sound like my friend david
when he's talking about food what you're
talking about
but you're like you know when you just
like just put someone in the face it's
just like
it's it's a weird martial artist you
know like he's that
it's art it's a passion for him yeah i
love the art and the aspect of like you
know the ability to like
transition from punching to an arm bar
and watching their arm bend the wrong
way
[Laughter]
there's an art to it because i think
that
i'm only speaking on behalf of people
who think
all forms of this or
or or aggression or violence or or
fighting is
all tapping into the same place but i
know that
there's sportsmanship there's the
there's the artistry behind
it and there is the art of like being a
warrior right
versus someone who's constantly in pain
and angry and they're just trying to
fight
everybody in the world there's a
difference between the two
but i think people who don't understand
that they see it all as
one thing they just think violence is
violent any hurt
fighting hitting someone is the same
thing no matter
what it is but then there is a
difference like there is a sportsmanship
side to it or like even art to it
but then there's also like people who
are just angry and need to fight all the
time
yeah and and there's a there's there are
those type of fighters to
um in the in the sport as well where
they'll fight on emotion on that anger
um but you know in my experience as far
as just being an athlete you look at any
top-end athlete in the world
they they don't use anger you know at
least at the high end
the there's cool calm collected until
they need to strike whatever it is
golf basketball baseball whatever you
know and the guys that
are using anger they're very fun to
watch whatever sport you're in
but generally it's it they don't get to
the very very top
is it because like their mind isn't
clear and it's like
it's like you know when you watch a
movie right and then one of the games
is to make your opponent angry so they
don't think clearly mm-hmm
yeah how's the judgment you know i think
natural ability you know speed
power um all that stuff can only take
you so far
um to get the very very top like this is
the thing that's going to separate
um everybody from everything else and
it's that mental strength that mental
power
and so you look at any champion in any
sport like that's what separates them
yes they're fast yes they're strong um
but there's something in here that makes
them different from everybody else
whether it's work ethic strategy you
know efficiency of their movements
or thinking or whatever has there ever
been a point where like you're training
because you how long have you been
uh fighting for about 17 years now
has it ever come to a point like in the
middle where you're like i'm going to
quit or i don't want to do this [ __ ]
anymore have you ever like faced
multiple times yeah multiple times
especially
after i got married and especially after
i got a kid um it gets
more difficult i mean i've essentially
dedicated my whole life to fighting
and uh the end goal was to get to the
ufc become a world champion
and here i am 17 years late 17 years
later
not there yet and so it's tough to tell
your family or your wife to be like hey
um sorry i can't make it home tonight i
can't make it home to dinner i haven't
been home
well until covet hit um i didn't make
dinner
for the whole time i was with my wife so
that's like what four or five years i
never made it home for dinner just
training
i've been training yeah our training
goes until like 9 p.m at night you know
we start at 11 a.m in the morning
but like how come you don't even have
here then you know uh
i'm here i i purposely try to keep my
ears away um from people
you did good thank you yeah because our
buddy nick is like his name is nick the
ear
yeah he has it here i mean his ear
should have its own name i know it's
it is it isn't here um but yeah i just i
a ton of my friends have cauliflower i
didn't want it and i didn't want to get
surgery to fix it
um so instead of driving with my ear i
drove with my temple
when you say driving with my ear instead
of that what's that for people who don't
know including myself
oh yeah so for like grappling generally
you do like head pressures like you try
like push somebody here but a lot of
times you'll push with your ear
to try to like take them down or throw
them down or something but i made a
small adjustment by utilizing my temple
um we don't have cauliflower temple then
yeah what's up with your temples
they're really nice i have cauliflower
it's probably a thick skull now
that's what they refer to as a thick
skull um but that little adjustment has
helped me a lot to
kind of just keep myself aesthetically
pleasing do people wear head gear too
and mma because i know
so i wrestle in high school and there's
a lot of dudes that have cauliflower
because they wrestle but then i like
also didn't want cauliflower ears i
always wore my head gear all the time
whereas a lot of people that don't they
get cauliflower is that normal in mma to
where
yeah it's it varies from jen and jim um
some gyms wear headgear some gyms don't
um our gym is really big on head gear
and so everybody wears it and
uh in case in point i was training with
one of my teammates giovera
um like a few months ago
and the one time i took my headgear off
he threw a hook right in my ear hole and
popped my eardrum
and then sure enough um
i heard i heard a weird ringing noise
and then once
i uh you know we were over i was like i
plugged my
test if your ears are popped you can
plug your nose and then blow into your
nose and
air was coming out of my ears i was like
dang it were you able to hear
oh yeah i could hear but there's like a
light ringing all the time
um and that that kind of sucks it
doesn't seem like much but if it's like
non-stop 24 7 i'm just like
you don't go like man i love my job
not at that point i mean at that point
like dang this sucks or
it wasn't even i wasn't thinking about
my job i was like i should have worn
headgear
and then my coach looked at me like yeah
you should have worn headgear i was like
i was thinking that i'm like and you
said it was like i was was i thinking
out loud
like what the heck what's the um like
the next step to get to the ufc
like what's the entry level like for
wrestling they have like that place you
go to and like everyone goes and
auditions basically like what's what's
that like
yeah so i mean there's uh it's almost
like baseball there's minor leagues in
major leagues
and so um minor leagues are kind of like
smaller regional promotions
and then you'll fight there
stereotypically the recipe
is you need three to five solid wins and
by solid they like they
you want to be good on camera it can't
be like decisions you can't just win
three to five good wins you need to be
like entertaining
but how come they keep on having shitty
fights then dude i watched so many
fights with guys just hugging on the
ground the whole time
um a lot of times they'll do that and
then for whatever reason because um
i train with a ton of ufc fighters that
ufc stage is different you get on that
stage and a lot of people choke or a lot
of people are worried it's like
okay i'm here now i can't be as reckless
um i can't be as wild but they're gay
time changes a lot of times yeah and a
lot of times too
just some people have a lot of good luck
and they just get in or maybe they're
from a region
that they're trying to build more of an
audience and so like let's say you're
from
i don't know timbuktu i don't even know
it's a real place
it's not real it's not okay there's no
such thing as timbuktu
but let's say ufc wants to build up more
of an audience from that region
right and so they'll they'll pick the
local fighters from that region um even
if they don't have that great of a
record just to get
let's get those eyeballs because the
local eyeballs will watch yep yep i mean
just like you see a lot more
asian fighters um being in the ufc now
right they're trying to build that asian
audience in china
china market yeah you know and then you
also see them putting a lot of time in
latin american fighters because they're
trying to build south america
so i will assume or anticipate that
you'll see a lot more shows
in china and south america when uh when
this covet thingy is over they built a
ufc pi over there oh yeah they already
built that china that crazy one
yeah so they're already making those
moves uh because it's a huge market i
mean china's a ton of people
and uh now they have a world champion
you know from china so
damn do you ever think at your age do
you think
it's too late to still make one last run
you think or
i remember you telling me like um you're
saying like you know with your record
because you do have good experience
but if you were 20 or 25 from the ufc's
point of view they're like okay i'll
take a chance on this guy because i can
get at least like three fights out of
him right
or five fights but then at your age with
your record that's where it's like
well how many more years can i get out
of this guy
is it even worth us putting him like
into the organization
yeah you know i'm 35 and most of these
kids are in the early 20s now
and you look at all the world champions
all of them generally become champion at
the early 30s um a lot of them or
you know younger they're like crazy
talented extra extra talented
but at 35 generally you got the talent
of your mma career you know and so for
me
my only chance of getting in the ufc is
if i'm ready
and they need somebody like within a few
days
oh like someone like like super last
night's their ankle or something they
need to make a sub
yeah and and nobody else is available
and then
i'm that guy that will come in and do it
and if you're in let's say you get in
for that
match right is that a televised map
guaranteed or like
yeah i mean television in some degree in
some degree whether it's a prelims or
whatever because they'll have
pay-per-view and then they'll have like
espn plus
and then they'll have like a ufc tv um
and all that stuff and so that
for me and my current point in my career
um that's
my only shot my best shot at getting in
otherwise i'll be fighting regionally
now if i want to fight in other
countries like uh for like risen
and uh one fc and stuff like that
organizations yeah other organizations
that are also big
around the world i have a much better
shot at getting in they're a little more
lenient
um as far as getting fighters in why
don't you fight in those ones is ufc
like the
kind of like it was the it was the
unicorn you know like uh i focused on a
souljah life i wanted you know
at this stage in my career i i still
want to aim for the ufc but if the other
promotions want to give me a shot i'm
happy to
but even one you know when i when i was
in um talks with them
they want me to get two or three solid
wins in because at my
this lap these last two years have been
really really inconsistent for me i've
knocked somebody out i'd lose i knocked
somebody out i'd leave that knock
somebody out i'd lose
i'm like i need to just knock people out
and not lose
well it's getting knocked out like um
like i stopped them uh either they go
unconscious or uh
for you like have you been knocked out
yeah i was there
i almost threw up i saw that one yes
when you see a fight on tv right and you
see someone get knocked out it's like
it's
you're kind of removed from it and
you're like oh [ __ ] i'm cheering i got
chips are flying everywhere yeah it's
almost like an
insane like like slam dunk that you just
watched yeah
but when you're personally connected to
someone it felt
so crazy to see like my coach too like
body gold limp
hit the ground and i almost wanted to
just throw up immediately it was crazy
my bad yeah i mean my whole career um
i'm known as a power hitter but my whole
career i've
i've never been knocked out and for
whatever reason just through bad luck
now whatever is my fault
but we came at the wrong time that was
my first yeah when he came to watch me
it's my first knockout
and then i thought it was a fluke you
know and so i was like oh man
like i can't believe that happened it
was uh it was a fluke that shouldn't
have happened
you know and so i fought again like a
few months later
and i got knocked out again but this
time i actually got a concussion
um concussions suck like don't downplay
it like i never
really experienced it firsthand but
having a concussion sucks
really really bad you're just hazy and
like not all there for like
an undetermined amount of time because
there's no protocol on when the cover is
going to be it's just whenever you
recover
so i was just daisy and hazy i felt like
i was high but i didn't want to be high
um for i think like good six months i
just wasn't
all there yeah it lasted a long time wow
yeah yeah it was
it was weird i was like man like and
then that finally
finally i learned my lesson the hard way
was like okay it wasn't a fluke it
happened
twice in a row and the same way same
exact way same exact punch
same exact scenario i was like i need to
change my ways and finally from then on
like my my game kind of switched over i
was like oh snap
um instead of hitting with a thousand
percent power now hit with 40 power
um and of course now that i'm 35 at the
tail of my career
i finally was able to realize that and
make that change but
there's still work that can be done do
you think that when bart saw you get
knocked out he should have walked up to
the other guy and asked him to be his
your teacher
that would have been hilarious you did
it like you are now my master
you're gonna go like the funny thing is
though like the whole
it was two rounds or one round it was
one round the whole one round he was
beating the
[ __ ] out of the other guy and it just
came around and boom
i remember you guys tell me about this
yeah i think he was just getting
comfortable so his hands started
dropping and the other guy was like
almost just like this
and just out of nowhere and it just
landed perfect perfect on the button
because we we were all cheering because
we thought like you were just beating
the [ __ ] yeah
and i inherited the i got excited like
the arena's getting louder and louder
and louder because i was like
and then um there was a break in action
and then even my head i was being so
dumb
i was like all right ron let's finish
this and of course i'm like
and i walked right in i was like dude
and then i woke up i was like dang it
i just got knocked out didn't i and the
rest is like yeah are you okay i'm like
as good as i'm gonna be i'm like and
then i put my head on his shoulders like
take him
hold
this sucks i've always wanted to ask a
fighter to this
so you you're is it are you ever like
that was [ __ ] why did you call it
so early i was totally fine or anything
like that you're like
on the ground i could have got up dude
like
watch yourself a flight did you see my
thumbs up
um yeah that was my my my my pro debut
and so as an amateur i i got i i was
four and oh
four fights in a row uh three knockouts
and then i won a local title called the
ifs
uh lightweight title congratulations
thank you it was cool um
and then uh what was epped up though
when i won the belt the belt was dope
but the person that lost got this trophy
that was like seven feet tall
and the trophy was way cooler than this
belt i was like
you should get the pick yeah i was like
can i have the trophy i'm like fudge oh
my god whatever i can
fight you for it i'll fight you for it
um and so i made my pro debut
and then of course you know i was i was
doing the same scenario i was like
beating this guy up and then i walked in
i was like all right let's do this i
walk in all of a sudden i walk right
into another hand
so you see this recurring issue with me
um i get dropped
and then uh but i'm fine i'm like i'm
fighting and all of a sudden
the doctor runs in and you can tell he
wasn't a rep because he was decked out
in ed hardy at the time
what the [ __ ] what kind of doctor is
this yeah
it was weird it was a weird situation he
came in and stopped the fight
but what's weird about that is doctors
aren't allowed to step into the cage to
stop the fight
the referees are the ones that stop the
fight and so the referee was like dude
what are you doing in the kid she
literally
unlocked the cage walked in and just
started waving off the fight
was he one of the official doctors or
something he was the caged side doctor
yeah he was a veterinarian
[Laughter]
he stopped the fight he came in and
stopped the fight you know
um and so is really where we um we even
contested the decision to make a no
decision like dude
why were the doctor going to stop the
fight i'm like i wasn't even unconscious
i was still
defending um and then um and so we never
actually showed up because it wasn't it
wasn't worthwhile
but funny enough of course not confirmed
but we made some assumptions
um that the doctor was friends with my
opponent at the time
so funny enough though we made enough of
a splash that the doctor was no longer
allowed to
to work fights anymore wow so at least
it won't hap it wouldn't it doesn't
hasn't happened to anybody else since
then but that was a that was a tough
break oh
i've never seen my coach matt before and
he was p he's scary
uh when he's mad and he came in he i
don't know where he found a chair
but a chair appeared out of nowhere in
the cage and he freaking threw the chair
and i was like how come i can't see this
kind of ufc [ __ ] i always see guys on
the floor just hugging
oh yeah it was pissed well you know the
the fight was online and they got pulled
oh really it got pulled after we we
tried contesting the uh
the decision until the the video got
pulled i was like
i'm like all right they're just trying
to cover up the [ __ ] yeah i was like
we're not going to win this one i'm like
let's just
not lose anymore okay but yeah and so
that was one of the times where it was
like really questionable
um the fighter did nothing wrong he did
everything great on his part he dropped
me
you know i was on defense mode but some
funky stuff was definitely happening
that day
[Music]
you